hi Carmichael welcome to another edition
of ask Evan in today's video I'm going
to answer question from one where
readers Diane was asking about if I use
the iPad as a teleprompter for making
these videos or not because I recently
posted a bill may I so her question is
effing approaches my iPad to use as a
teleprompter for video that we're
creating have you use your iPad this way
and what you recommend to make this use
for successful Diane so then I don't use
an iPad as a teleprompter I've heard of
people doing it but I haven't tried it
myself so the videos that I create here
I do a couple things what I'm talking to
the camera it's always usually off the
cup so if I'm reading a question like it
just read yours I have pieces of paper
and you seem to look there because I'm
leaving the question I tried to do that
for too long but you see I have pages of
notes here these are three pages of
questions that I'm answering questions
for my readers what I usually to a nap
question is I'll write down a couple
point form notes of things that I want
to talk about and then when i get in
front of the camera i'll just talk and
hopefully remember those points it's
never exactly what i wrote down but I'm
just answering the question as best as I
can walk up and more having a
conversation and try to remember a
strict script in the past I did try to
remember script and I found that it
wasn't natural and
kind of thinking of what I was supposed
to say and it didn't go well in my
opinion so I found that these videos
were a lot better I also only try to
answer questions that I think I actually
answer and have some knowledge on moms
they don't know everything about
everything so just try to answer the
questions that i can speak comfortably
about the other types of video i'll do
is the model in damascus video or
special videos that that are longer and
where I have to stay on message and I
want to tell stores certain way and for
those who do is what I'll do is I'll
always open up with the video of me so
being mean welcoming the reader the
viewer I'll also close the video saying
no thank you for joining me for this new
video and encourage people to leave
feedback and usually throughout the
video I'm not making other parents to
highlight some key points again on video
and it'll just be me you know
remembering key points that I want to
talk about but most video will be me
reading something and the video itself
will have pictures that correlate to
what I'm talking about so that's
situational just you know how come I
don't read a script that I want to make
sure that that message is conveyed and
my video editor will throw in pictures
that relate to what I'm talking about so
those are for some of my longer videos
what I'm not just talking up the
comprehension questions so I hope that
helps I haven't used the ipad yet as a
you know that's helicopter if you knew
would love to hear experiences if you
guys like this video too i'd love to
hear your feedback if you want to leave
a comment below this video and I also
always appreciate thumbs up if you want
to give that on the video and stay tuned
to the next episode
you
I
you